good
afternoon my name is Amy McCree and I'm
the coordinator of technology and
culture Forum at MIT and the Episcopal
chaplain at MIT and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to this
afternoon's event technology and culture
forum is one of the three sponsors of
this event the other two are the
communications Forum at MIT and the
center for future Civic media at MIT
it's a great pleasure to be working
alongside those two groups on this event
which is it turns out is the third in a
three-part series which began over a
year ago last fall we did two forums
together both of them were about media
and the elections the first centered on
traditional media and its role in the
elections and the second was on New
Media and both of those were wonderful
Lively discussions where we heard lots
of views on a really important issue
so this forum has been sort of a long
time in the Genesis but I'm glad that it
took a while to come together because
things have gotten even more interesting
and the landscape has gotten even more
complex and there's uh infinitely more
even now to talk about regarding race
and politics in the media and we're very
fortunate this evening to have two uh
tremendous people with us to help us uh
take a look at this topic and begin to
uh get a sense of what going on and why
so without much more introduction I want
to uh ask you to give a round of
applause sorry uh to our moderator for
this evening's conversation David
thorburn is the director of the
communications Forum at MIT and a
professor of literature at MIT and he's
going to introduce our two speakers and
uh help moderate the conversation this
evening so uh with that let's give a
round of applause to
David
thank you very much
Amy uh one of the joys of collaborating
with various outfits at MIT is are the
kinds of connections you make and I I
always think of Amy as the spiritual
advisor to the to the communications
forum and even though I don't attend
church or synagogue or any such thing I
think of Amy as my spiritual
representative as as many at MIT
do it's a great pleasure to uh introduce
our two speakers today our our format
will be the usual Communications format
Communications Forum format in which the
three of us will sort of engage in a
kind of conversation for the first part
of the session and then we will switch
over to what is almost always the
liveliest and most interesting part of
the Forum uh question and answer session
with you and the audience so I urge you
to sharpen your wits and sharpen your
tongues and uh we will give all of you
plenty of time to interact with the
speakers
I let me briefly introduce our speakers
today uh to my to my far right is my
colleague Jay Philip Thompson who's an
associate professor of urban uh planning
and politics at MIT uh and most re and
the author most recently of a book
entitled Double Trouble black Mayors
black
communities and the search for a deep
democracy I love the phrase deep
democracy when when when uh Philip and I
were in conversations about this forum
and there were some folks we were trying
to get to join us that we were unable to
I called him at one point or he called
me at one point to say someone that we
had hoped to get wasn't available and in
the middle of the conversation while we
were working on the conversation he said
listen I can't talk for too long now
because I'm preparing Congressional
testimony and I'm appearing tomorrow
morning so leave me alone I hope your
testimony was successful Philip but but
it's a mark of the influence that his
his uh work has had that he is uh uh
regularly involved in such uh
significant uh work up non-scholarly
work as well as significant
scholarship I suppose in some degree all
of you know who Juan Williams is uh so I
won't take too long in introducing him
but I do want to mention a couple of
things as most of you know he's the
senior correspondent for national public
radio and a political analysts for the
Fox News Channel he's a regular panelist
on the Weekly News Affairs program Fox
News Sunday and uh a regular on The
O'Reilly Factor perhaps his most
problematic job some of us
feel uh uh uh Juan Williams began his
professional career uh at the Washington
Post and and worked at the Washington
Post in a variety of capacities for over
23 years he served as an editorial
writer an oped columnist and the white
White House correspondent and National
correspondent what is less widely know
known about him although people who pay
attention to the bestseller list might
realize this is that he's also a
prolific writer and among his books is a
biography of thur Good Marshall that was
recently re-released in with an updated
epilogue in 2008 he's the author of The
essays in a book of photographs uh and
essays titled black farmers in America
uh and the photographs are by John
ficara and that was published in 2006
I'm not going to list all his titles
because he's more prolific than most
tenur professors uh but I do want to
mention one other important book that
many of you have heard of he's the
author of the book eyes on the prize
America's civil rights years 194 54 to
65 a companion volume to the television
series that many of many of you may have
heard of uh and uh he's published a
range of other uh uh books on as off on
aspects of the black experience so he's
he's is especially well qualified uh not
just because of his experience as a
journalist but because of his work as a
writer to address the kinds of broad
questions we're going to be talking
about in today's
Forum with those introductions behind us
let me Begin by asking Juan Williams to
talk a bit
about given his long career as a
journalist about the ways in which he
thinks the world of Journalism has if it
has opened more fully to minorities and
especially to African-Americans when
when one reflects on it I mean the fact
is that he's an immensely prominent and
influential journalist 30 years ago it
would be very unlikely that that that an
African-American would occupy the kind
of distinguished uh uh position that uh
Mr Williams occupies in American society
today and I I I thought we might begin
one by asking you to talk a bit about
your own experiences coming up as a
journalist and how you think the world
of Journalism has
changed oh Professor thorberg uh
Professor Thompson thank you for joining
me and I appreciate the invitation to be
with all of you tonight look forward to
the interactive part of this session
with the audience going back and forth
um you know for me getting out of
Washington and being in touch with all
of you here uh is a real pleasure
uh it really is a pleasure to be around
people who have good questions serious
questions and important dialogue so
thank you all for coming um I guess I
would start off by making this sort of a
biographical answer um and say that you
know my mom uh used to come home on this
off the subway in New York and we lived
in Brooklyn and she worked as a garment
worker in lower Manhattan and so she
would bring me newspapers as a child uh
newspapers that were left on the subway
uh by businessmen even some newspapers
that were left by businessmen going over
to New Jersey so I'd see the New Jersey
papers as well as in New York City City
papers and we're talking here about
1960s and so we're talking about a time
when New York City had seven I believe
seven newspapers unlike today you think
of New York New York and you think of
the New York Times the New York Post New
York daily news then you had just a
plethora of titles heral World telegram
Journal americ all this uh at work and
for me one of the great pleasures of uh
being a kid at that time for me was
baseball and I used to read different
sports writers in different Publications
and compare them and think well this guy
got in the locker room he knows what
he's talking about this guy looks like
he was drunk or this guy's having a
fight with his wife he doesn't care he
didn't even understand the key point in
the game and um so for me this was like
Wow wouldn't it be great to be a
journalist you know you get a ticket to
the game you get inside the action it's
an opportunity to help people to
properly explicate what seems to be just
entertainment but actually is a matter
of skill and strategy and and quite a
fascinating game now um part of this
then this experience was noticing of
course that there were no people of
color telling these stories uh there
were then just coming into the picture
uh this was after the years of Jackie
Robinson obviously but just coming into
the picture were more players of color
no managers of color obviously no owners
of color and certainly no news paper
Publishers of color what struck me in
this mix was the absence uh the only
time that I would see a or hear about a
journalist of color was when I saw a
copy of the Amsterdam news which was
published in Harlem uh and then
sometimes on Sundays uh there would be
like a Community Affairs program uh that
would occur um on some of the channels
and it would be with a black host and
they would seem to be paying attention
to issues of concern to the black
community but uh for the most part it
was sort of a fantasy of mine to think
well you know how could I break through
now I was the editor of my junior high
school paper editor of my high school
paper I worked when I went off to a prep
school I worked as a journalist covering
things like NAACP meetings or issues in
the black community because they didn't
have any reporters who went into the
black part of pipy New York and so I
didn't play uh football or anything like
that and occasionally I would go off and
they wouldn't pay me for doing these
stories but they would give me a byline
and for me that was worth more than the
money I was just thrilled to go out and
be able to write a story that would end
up in the local paper and then when I
went off to college I went to haford
college in
Pennsylvania um for the first year I did
not work on the paper because I was
concerned about meeting the academic
requirements of that institution and um
but that summer I applied to work at the
big city paper which was then an
afternoon daily call the Philadelphia
evening bulletin it was the biggest
paper in the city at that time and again
it's just telling as we sit here in 2009
we don't even have afternoon papers in
the United States today but imagine in
this city Philadelphia uh then guess
might still be but about the fourth
biggest city in the country the biggest
paper is the afternoon paper and uh and
I applied for a job
there and didn't just sent
recommendations and clips from my work
at elsewhere and uh did not put my age
or a picture and got the internship and
I remember when I showed up of course I
was the only intern of color and I was
younger than mostly interns who were
either graduate students or seniors in
college and I remember the managing
editor when he came in to meet with us
um called me out of the room and said
which one are you and how how old are
you and I said who I was and that I was
19 years old I think I was 18 actually
and um he said uh in something that one
of these things these lines that get
seared into your memory he said to me
this is not a babysitting operation and
you lied to us uh about your age I said
I didn't lie I just didn't put it in
there and he then asked me to leave um
but it turns out there were people at
haford who knew people who worked as
journalist at this publication and they
call back and said you know hey the the
kid you know has summer housing here you
hired him you why don't you give him a
chance and so they gave me a job for two
weeks that the the deal was well we'll
give him a try out for two weeks and
then the issue was never raised again
and I finished that summer then they
hired me to work uh two days a week
during the school years of sophomore and
then they hired me the next summer um
and then they hired me again three days
during the week for my uh junior year
and then I got a dow Jones newspaper
fund internship and I went to work at
the Providence Journal in Rhode Island
and again just to come back to your
theme there were some black journalist
very few in number at the Philadelphia
bulletin uh I can think of one woman who
was on the city desk who was like to me
the black Brenda star at the time and
then there was a very good boxing uh
writer um in the sports department but
that was it um and at the Providence
Journal there none so for me it often
felt as if you know remember at this
time I had a big fro I didn't look like
this right I had a big fro I'm skinny as
a reed I often come in with purple cons
on
uh you know I look like a a dandelion
you know the big fro and the skinniness
and I remember you know like people in
Philadelphia because at one point during
one of my stints there I was the number
two guy at City Hall and I remember
Frank Rizzo and if you know and the
people at the police department they
just had no concept how to deal with a
black
journalist um you know especially one
that was young and had this big afro and
was asking all these question just had
never dealt with anybody of color in the
position to tell the story and to hold
them to account in that fashion and uh
it made for an interesting tension again
that made it very clear to me that they
were I don't threatened is the word that
comes to mind but I think threatened is
too strong a word but that for them it
was a shifting of relationship to a
person of color um and and and that they
were going to they could not they had to
expect that there were questions that
were going to be forthcoming that they
had not dealt with before since the
person with the pen was a person of
color and of course that got back to
management um would had to make
sometimes uh difficult decisions so uh
and then after that then I got an
internship at the Washington Post um and
the person who selected me for that
internship turns out was a black City
editor um and that black City editor was
close to the man who at the time was the
prince of the Washington Post a man
named Don Graham who went on to be the
publisher of the paper his mother
kathern Graham obviously was the
publisher at that time but they had both
gone to Harvard they had both worked in
Vietnam and uh that's how herb had made
his way to Herb Denton the city editor
had made his way to the Washington Post
and then herb was someone who was
looking for promising journalists of
color to bring into this
institution and uh and I was the lucky
benefactor beneficiary of his uh
decision to bring me on and and this K
was a difficult time in the history of
the post because right after the riots
and the assassination of Dr King in '
68 uh the post and I think other major
American institutions had a wave of
black journalists come in they they
brought them in uh realizing that there
had been such rank discrimination and
that they just looked out of touch and
they were unable to properly cover
minority communities in crisis um but
what happened was you know it's so
telling you know often times those
journalists were not given by lines or
not put in charge of writing they were
sent out to do this to gather
information or go into these minority
communities where white journalists
might feel threatened or uncomfortable
and then they would feed the information
back to the White journalist who would
write the stories um and the black
journalists felt they weren't moving up
weren't being promoted in these
newsrooms and then they had filed a
lawsuit at the Washington Post against
management and that her her my mentor
had been outside of that group and so he
was being you know there was attention
among the black journalist over this
kind of issue um and then I come now
along after graduating from haford in 76
and I'm sort of a second wave of black
journalists coming in and herb is
looking for people who have had
substantial experience in training as
journalist so that they will be in
position to move up and to compete more
uh successfully against their white
peers in The Newsroom uh and to really
blow past some of these bar barriers so
uh that's the situation I come into and
of course I come into Washington DC uh a
city that is predominantly black and uh
a city going through all sorts of power
struggles of its own over its
relationship to the federal government
so this is uh I think I feel like i'
I've spoken too long here so I'm going
to stop but but that's the sort of
that's the Basin of my or the roots of
my experience or my growth growth as an
American journalist one thing that
strikes me from from the account you're
giving it's is is that old that old
cliche from Marx about when history
repeats itself a second time it's farce
right uh because what you're describing
in a way sounds like something more
contemporary where the where where uh uh
in which uh a situation in which uh
various news organizations become
terribly uneasy about their in about the
inadequate way in which they're covering
racial materials and they I one of the
things I was thinking about was I hope
some of you noticed this because it
seemed very obvious to me right after
Obama's election many more African
American faces started to appear as
television anchors uh no one said
anything about it none of the networks
acknowledged what they were doing but it
seems to me as if it was a sort of
reenactment of what you've described in
which uh in which the sort of uh uh
established authorities became so uneasy
about the ways in which they were sort
of failing to cover things that that
that they they they did did this sort of
reach out and I I'm wondering if or let
let me pose the question in a broader
way that has to do with the way we
formulated our argument for this forum
uh you may recall the the basic
description of this forum is goes like
this the election of an African-American
president in 2008 has been hailed as a
transforming event but has Obama's
Ascension transformed anything many
people's answer to that question changed
in the summer when skip Gates was
arrested at his home in Cambridge are
the harsh realities of race and class in
the United States clearer now or murkier
following the media tsunami of
gatesgate and has this polarizing event
given greater visibility to racial
minorities in the media's coverage of
politics let's begin with those
questions well it's sort of a broad yes
agenda but let me just go to the
question of has this brought more voices
of color in into the picture the
election of President Obama I think the
most obvious uh consequence of Obama's
election is if you look at the number of
commentators of color I think that has
increased I think if you look at some of
the political discussions especially on
cable networks notably on CNN I would
point to uh I think you see more faces
of color and younger people uh suddenly
represented uh and it's interesting you
know at the White House these days you
have correspond is there from Essence
and the like never people who would
never have had a seat at the table but
it's also that they never asked for a
seat at the table now with Obama there I
think with the celebrity quoti you get
lots of Publications that are that
market to audiences of color wanting to
be there at the white house because they
realize their readership Their audience
is fascinated and tied in emotionally to
uh the doings of the Obama
Administration but when you said you see
more anchors I was wondering what you
were looking at because I don't see more
anchors I meant the commentators yeah I
don't see any more anchors of color and
even you know I occupy a very strange
Terrain in that the Sunday morning talk
shows in Washington are pretty much a
conversation among Elite white males and
I'm the only person of color who is
there every week uh my friend Donna
Brazil pops up I'd say once every two or
three weeks uh on the ABC program with
George
Stephanopoulos uh once in a while uh you
might see uh Michelle naris who's also
with NPR or Jee Robinson The Washington
Post columnist pop up on Meet the Press
but in general it's a conversation among
older white males uh on Sunday mornings
which is kind of the time that
Washington gets dressed up to address
our most influential audiences and talk
to our most powerful players um and if
you then go backwards from that and
start thinking about things like the
Nightly News programs um the news there
in terms of breakthrough is women white
women breaking through uh Diane Sawyer
being the latest but of course Katie
kurri a few years ago uh to join into
that Elite fraternity but there's no PE
there's no people of color Who present
the Nightly News as anchors in this
country and when I get involved in
conversations about hosting shows and
this comes up in my life uh I would say
if if not annually you know twice
annually uh essentially it always comes
down to well is the audience going to
relate to a black male as the lead dog
if you will in this conversation and I
tell you the most chilling conversation
ation of this kind I've ever had was
with a an executive at a black cable
network who said you
know black men especially who would
identify with you um like to watch
sports and pornography but we're not
convinced they're going to watch the
news and I said you know that's crazy I
can't walk a blocking this country and
I'm talking about and blocking any
neighborhood much less going to a an
airport or uh go to the gym without
people saying hey you're Juan Williams
and here's what I think and why aren't
you telling why aren't you saying what I
think and they are just as likely to be
uh black men as anybody else uh who see
a face that they recognize from TV or a
voice that they know is on the radio
talking about politics but again in
terms of the the game that the
executives play and even Executives at
uh organization that
are focused on the minority audience
there's just not a belief that the
minority audience is going to respond to
a high level of political uh discourse
in this country I think if you look at
the history of bet for example it's just
pretty Stark in terms of the absence of
news product um and uh the failure to
invest in news product there to me is is
sinful um uh TV1 has had no news product
even to the point of being embarrassed
about failing to cover something like
the funeral of ketta Scott King and
other events like that they're now
starting I think just last week or two
weeks ago to try to have a Sunday
morning program I used to host a show
called America's black Forum which would
a in the early mornings on Saturday and
Sunday often in community or or
community service I forget what that
slot is called and it used to be
required by FCC of of broadcasters but
that's been done away with but anyway
this program had come out of that era
and then I had taken over as host uh
James Brown who does CBS football was
another host for a while and so we would
do stories of issues and concern major
newsmakers in the Black and Hispanic uh
Community uh but that show was bought
now I guess two years ago um and what
they did was they wanted to make it more
hipop more celebrity oriented and they
belied that would help that show to move
up the show is just about falling off
the map I think as a result uh I don't
follow it very closely but it just
doesn't have the presence that it used
to have uh in the marketplace but the
key here again is uh to my mind the
failure of Institutions uh major
American Media Med institutions to
meet you know it's a difference between
catering to an audience and pandering to
an audience and I think in many cases
rather than cater or even raise the
standards of news consumption and
relevance of news for the minority
Community they have chosen to Pander to
what I think are the lowest instincts in
terms of that community so you will have
no trouble if you go home tonight in
turning on uh music videos and Comedians
and sporting
events uh and you know uh light sex
content type Productions but you will
have a hell of a time if you're trying
to find news content that is aimed at
the minority Community black Hispanic
Asian in the United
States let's let's pursue this idea
about this the issue of minority uh so
minority news sources for a moment and I
hope we'll return to sort of questions
having to do with major media in a in a
moment but one of the things that has
been argued uh fairly uh urgently by
some observers of the universe of
Journalism in the United States has been
uh that with the decline of newspapers
because of the problems about
advertising rates and the way in which
the the way in which the internet has
undermined their readership in so many
ways and the idea that newspapers are a
dying phenomenon or at least a declining
a deeply declining one one argument has
been made that one of the effects of
this has been especially bad for
minority communities because the small
newspapers uh the newspapers and and
that are that are aimed at minority
communities are suffering even more and
more some of them are going out of
business can't find can't find finances
and I'm wondering whether uh what what
your impression is of that problem not
just with regard to minority newspapers
but other forms in which minority voices
can be systematically heard and I hope
you'll come in on this Phil why don't
you start no no this is you're the
expert on this no I'm not the expert
that's why I I was trying
to you know effectively seed the table
because I didn't have much to say uh the
when it comes to smaller journals and
obviously I T I've worked for my
experiences with the Washington Post you
know uh I you know I do op-eds for New
York Times The Wall Street Journal USA I
I'm I work for mainstream white
Publications and then of course Fox News
and NPR again
mainstream overwhelmingly in terms of
Their audience and their leadership
white organizations so I don't have a
tremendous wealth of experience in this
area but I can as an observer and as a
consumer of this news uh when I look at
what has come of minority uh uh
newspapers and minority broadcast in the
country here's what I see I see that
Minority newspapers are pretty much on
the edge if not going out of business in
terms of the old style and here I'm
thinking of things like Amsterdam news
that I grew up with or Pittsburgh
Courier or uh Baltimore afroamerican uh
Washington afroamerican um that used to
be major voices in their Community I
mean they used to be the Bible when I do
work research in terms of historical
research you know I have to go to Black
newspapers to understand what's going on
in terms of movement politics in terms
of life in the black community uh
there's nothing comparable to my mind
you don't until you hit the brown
decision in 54 even in such August
journals as the New York Times you are
not getting coverage of the minority
Community uh you know it's it's really
tragic to see see things like uh
obituaries in which people don't even
have names but are referred to as you
know Aunt Sarah who was uh made in
Mr David thorberg home you know uh
that's that's their own that's and
that's the reason would be that he's a
professor at MIT and therefore his
servant is being given some
acknowledgement in our paper today and
that would be the only basis her
Humanity her life uh her family life
would be uh if not uh an afterthought
secondary so that moment when you had
minority newspapers playing such a key
role was also reflected then um began to
decline I should say after 54 and has
been going downhill and downhill even
more rapidly with the emergence of a
black middle class in the country in the
course of the
1980s and into the 199 90s so much so
that um it's for me now you know
something that occasionally I pick up uh
the afro americ in Washington or the
Washington Informer these are small
black oriented newspapers uh they do not
have the resources in fact uh Ben jalis
who's now head of the NAACP at one point
was head of something called The Negro
newspapers association association uh
isn't nnpa wasn't it used to be n negro
yeah okay but it's changed not to be
black newspap and his and he was trying
to find some way to revive this group of
newspapers by bringing them together you
know sort of economies of scale so that
they could benefit through collaboration
publishing agreements on the light but
it was very difficult uh to try to bring
new life into these Publications and
some of them are still struggling along
um but overall especially in New York
you know Phil Philadelphia um DC again
an afterthought um even even in the
black middle class uh communities the
other part of this though is that
whereas you
have um such a
small representation in terms of the
newspaper world you had a bigger
representation in terms of things like
Jet Magazine ebony uh Essence is a very
successful has been a very successful
publication so there's magazines that
have grown especially grown with the
growth of the black middle class in the
country and then you have black radio
and black radio has absolutely been
thriving I mean you have tremendous
success with people like Tom joer Steve
Harvey uh as mourning voices to the
black community um and I would say
what's really curious to me is if you
look for black talk show hosts you can
now find them on serus and X M and
there's specific bands uh dedicated to
that content it it may be that one of
the you know the old saying from Dr King
about how 11:00 on Sunday morning used
to be the most segregated hour in
American Life uh as people went to
churches now I think you might say that
when people are tuning into their talk
show host uh you may come across again a
world that is almost completely
segregated who chooses to listen to the
right-wing talk show host versus who
chooses to listen list to Black talk
show I don't think the white Community
has come up with an answer for
limbo uh you know uh maybe Ed Schultz
who's now in M uh MSNBC might you know
be in that Universe they tried air
America and the like uh now Senator Al
Frank and tried for a while never quite
got it but in the black community black
talk show hosts oftentimes local black
talk show hosts are
quite uh dominant and influential I'm
thinking here of is it Michael bason who
was so key in terms of generating
support for the Jenna 6 and calling
attention to that issue getting people
to go down to Louisiana to March again
that's the power of local black radio as
a platform and I don't think that has
been in fact I think that has been
growing not being diluted uh in modern
America
today so are we wait a second wait a
second you got to take some of the
weight
here I was going to pose a question for
Phil but go feel no I agree with that I
I would only add that uh when I was uh
growing up I grew up in Philadelphia um
the uh inquire had a lot of news uh
coverage the Philadelphia inquire did um
uh in there were black journals when I
went to college we all read the black
scholar uh which was dialogue amongst
black activists in colleges basically um
analyzing all kinds of issues there's
nothing like that now
um there was a newspaper out of DC that
we used to read called the African World
um edited by Milton Coleman who I think
ended up at the Washington Post at one
time and it used to cover the debates
that were going on on amongst black
students actually and Community
activists over pan-africanism
versus uh revolutionary nationalism
versus cultural nationalism versus you
know all different kinds of views being
aired out in the newspapers and we read
those things assiduously and you don't
see anything like thatmore so one
implication of our conversation is that
the decline of newspapers maybe from
certain angles is even more serious for
the minority Community than it is than
it is for the for the majority that
there with with with the exception of
these of of these uh of this of these
radio talk show folks who are who are
who are reaching a niche Community not
the broader Community it seems as if
there's less coverage of minority
affairs s less attention to uh to uh
pressing social problems having to do
with African-Americans and minorities
generally than there had been before do
you think that's really the case I would
not put it on the internet though um I
think the decline started before the
internet you mean talking about the
source of the problem and there was a
documentary film by Stanley Nelson
called soldiers without swords about the
history of the black press that I would
recommend and one of the things I
remember growing up um from my
grandparents they read the black papers
religiously and in the film they show
black sleeping car Porters on trains
going through cotton fields in
Mississippi where the Chicago uh
Defender was illegal and the porters
were throwing off bundles of the
newspapers in the cotton fields and then
there were people who knew where the
drops were who would pick up the papers
and there were a quarter million papers
a week being distributed throughout the
south in that way um and it gave me you
know some insight into my grandparents
about why it was the newspaper was just
so important to them well it gives me
some insight into the power of
Journalism at a certain time yes that's
very interesting and there's no
equivalent to that in terms of print I
uh I get has to do with the the real
source is not so much the internet but
the decline of print in general well I I
think for them the newspaper was where
you got really Vital Information about
about how the community is going to
advance or what's happening to the
community in in other places and
something Juan said that was interesting
to me is that the black middle
class um maybe doesn't need that or
feels that get information from other
sources to um satisfy those needs or
perhaps it is uh perhaps there's a need
for newspapers that address uh
communities that are not middle class
that have particular needs um but don't
feel that any black paper is speaking
directly to them um about their needs um
and that may be another source of um
declining interest well you know what's
you take the Washington Post for
example again you're talking about a
local a city that's predominantly black
but of course the the paper serves the
region and especially those white
suburbs that's where the bulk of the
circulation is to be found but the inner
city is clearly uh mostly black and that
newspaper covers news in the black
community uh obviously local news but in
terms of even National controversies for
example you wouldn't have to find a
black newspaper over the last few days
to have read about Daren Albert the
16-year-old who was beaten to death in
Chicago you don't have to go to a black
publication to get this now in the
1950s and and pre before the 50s you
would have had to go to a black
publication to hear about a black child
dying even if it was a VI particularly
violent death but now in Big City
Newspapers you will get that coverage as
you know a crisis situation obviously if
you have a black president you're going
to get coverage of the president uh you
don't have to go to a specialty
publication in terms of minority racial
uh interest that's in the big city paper
and again if they're serving a
population such as the population in
Washington DC and they're trying to hold
circulation in any way they can they'd
be foolish not to include this content
but as I said you see it in the New York
Times you see it in USA Today it's there
and again this is a departure and for
this generation here in the audience
tonight you might think well gosh you
mean there was a time when they wouldn't
cover something like this yes and not
too far in the past but I I would say I
worked in New York politics for about 10
years and
um you know you're you're hearing a lot
of coverage now about Charlie Wrangle
and his house in the Dominican Republic
and things like that um and that's being
covered in you know
everywhere within the within
Harlem um there's been a lot of
criticism for Charlie Wrangle not about
things like that um but about what his
prominence in Congress has not meant um
for local residents and that's the kind
of thing that at one time in history
you'd find a lot of back and forth in
things like the black scholar or things
like local papers in the Amsterdam news
used to have more reporters who covered
these sorts of opinions no one knows
what um the head of Johnson houses the
public housing project in East Harlem
the head of the residents Association
thinks about about Charlie Wrangle
that's not in the New York Times that's
not in the Daily News it's nowhere and
but in the community that's a real issue
um and so I think there's there's been a
change it's true you will read about a
shooting a or a kid being killed in high
school in you know a mainstream
newspaper you'll read about Charlie
Wrangle and his financial problems and
the Dominican Republic now um but the
voice of the community and the debates
that I heard all the time well working
in politics in New York I don't see in
those papers right right do you think
it's possible that if it doesn't exist
now that this these kinds of voices
might reemerge they've partly reemerged
as onean suggests in talk radio but do
you think they might reemerge on the
internet that there are that that
there's that there might be U uh ways
that that that these Community Voices
could aggregate maybe in ways they
haven't yet done but that they but that
might be possible it seems theoretically
the case that that should work but the I
guess part of the uh problem has to do
with access to the net and how how often
people have the habit of going on to it
and using it in that way but it would
see people would argue that one of the
that some of what traditional newspapers
have done is migrating in willy-nilly
and in in inadequately in odd fashion to
the
net these communal voices aren't there
yet well I'll start this I I think there
are a lot of possibilities that have not
been
realized um and the internet being an
example and there are some legal
barriers but I I think there are some
mindset barriers and I I'll give you an
example I used to be in charge of
management for New York City public
housing and uh about five years ago I
got a call from someone who works for
IBM who told me that the New York City
Housing Authority was uh um installing
fiber optic cable to every single um
unit of housing in in the Housing
Authority in in New York which is
200,000 units about 600,000 people um
are reached and the optic cable would
not only carry the security you know
video um stream so they could buzz in
people into the buildings but it would
carry cable news um as well as the
internet and everything else and the P
IBM was bidding for the contract to
install the fiber optics but they asked
me why aren't the residents NE
organizing since they already have a
residence Association Citywide why
aren't they forcing the um information
carriers Time Warner and others to
compete over the contract for who's
going to provide that information for
200,000 households and we had some
students here at the time Randall pinket
who then went on The Apprentice and won
and sort of dropped this project but for
a while he was working on this and uh he
did a study and he estimated that um
agreement that contract might be worth
about 30 to 50 million a year for the
residents Association so we then began
talking to the residents wow we could
have our you could have your own show
you could have your own news program for
public housing people will want to come
on your program politicians and others
you know you could do a lot of things
with this um and with $30 million a year
we're talking about real quality you
know we're not talking about what we see
you know the sixth grade class and their
annual glee club or whatever we're
talking about real quality you could do
this point being there are opportunities
to use media creatively to do things I
believe that um communities really
aren't there's not like a movement um
and there's we aren't even educating our
students here who could be doing these
things to actually take advantage of
these kinds of opport unities um that
exist so yes I think it's largely
theoretical at this point second thing I
would say is this there is a class
divide in Black America now that's uh
different there have always been class
divides but it's different and I'm not
sure how this is going to be mediated
and I just think we can't talk about
Black Americans like as one group um and
I I just want to give a a personal
example
um since you talked about your your
biography I just want to I I published
this book in 2006 and it's an academic
book um and I have a cousin younger
cousin I'm from Philadelphia I have a
younger cousin who's a uh criminal and
she runs a successful criminal
Enterprise and she's a lot younger than
me and um she she sent her she probably
richer than you too she drives a much
nicer car um she sent herself to Temple
University paid for it herself and she
said Phil nobody was offering
scholarships when I was trying to go to
college you all got a scholarships there
are no such things so don't judge me you
know I I this is how I did it and the in
2006 the same time I published my book
she published a book and out of her
criminal Enterprise um she started a
Publishing Company and she publishes
other
criminals and they sort of change the
names and write about their own lives
and their own experiences and then she
did a lot of marketing of the book you
know and her book is on the Barnes &
Nobles like list you know way down there
mine isn't um but my aunt de moral that
my no here's my criminal Behavior pays
better than profession no no no here it
is my my family even though we were core
I was it was drilled into me college
graduate school you know make something
of yourself publish a book and so my
family wanted to have this celebration
of like okay you're a professor you did
a book a second that's what we want you
know but my aunt whose granddaughter is
the criminal her book just came out so
my aunt said no we're gonna have a joint
book
party for both of you and I and I have
to say the contradictions were really
evident right in the room you know it's
it's a really different life experience
my cousin is every bit as smart as I am
but her whole circle a whole generation
within my own family they are completely
in a different world uh than that that I
you know my world and I can't say that
you're going to reach both of these
worlds on the same medium in the same
way right right that seems that seems a
very important thing to say that I even
wonder sometimes if the coverage both in
on television and the national the
national news programs and in the major
national papers is in so far as it
contains stories about African-Americans
it it often seems to me as as if it's
about middleclass African-Americans not
about uh uh workingclass people not
about not about the large number of
unemployed not not not and and in that
sense it seems to me the there's one of
the problems is of course that the
readers are their P newspapers reach out
to their readers and the readers may be
middle class and that may be a part of
the a part of the issue so is one
conclusion we could draw here that the
that that despite the fact that we're
we're not we're things have certainly
changed I mean the fact that you're a
professor and you're a prominent uh uh
commentator and and recognizable in
airports is certainly a change from what
it would have been like 30 years ago 50
years ago no no one would argue that but
one of the ironies is that with all the
fact that we do have so many more so
many prominent minorities has it how
substantially do you think it's actually
changed social conditions in the real
world I'll start and and I want to tell
another story I used to teach at
Columbia University after working in
city government and um I used to tell
some of my students like Ben jealous at
the time um don't think you can do off-
campus the same things you can do on
campus because Columbia University is in
Harlem um and on campus I'd often walk
in dormitories and I'd smell
marijuana um if you walked the the
police never came on campus and broke
down doors and arrested people for
marijuana on campus never ever that
didn't happen you walk one block off
campus you if you're if if there are
police if they smell marijuana you're
busted there were Rockefeller drug laws
mandatory sent sing hard time and so I
would tell black students you know
you're in a Zone here but you have to
understand this is a protected space and
you're still black and if you walk one
block off this campus you're getting
busted if you're doing some of the
things you do on this campus that's the
reality and so yes you do have blacks at
MIT and at Colombia and some in
positions that is true
but however you walk one block off and
there's a different thing going on there
um and I would say it's a little
different in the from the past as well
um I mean you could call it racial
targeting or or that sort of thing but
when I was growing up you didn't have
prison as a way of life um my family
they call it Camp they don't even call
it prison you know where is Johnny well
he's a camp
can't um it's it's a very serious thing
um and so I I think both things have
happened in the last 20 to 30 years and
Bruce Weston at Harvard did a study um
he said if you drop out of high school
and you're an African-American male you
have a 60% chance of doing hard time
before you turn 35 um and that's about
half that don't finish High School um
and drop out and 60% of that number
that's a different from when I was
growing gr up so both things have
changed and I say there's a a kind of
class divide
that's different do you think when I
grew up do either of you think that
these these realities are being
adequately covered in the mainstream
press do you think that the New York
Times or NBC
News has been adequate in its in in in
in their in their response to these
kinds of
issues well there's several things I
want to say and I'll come to this in a
second but I think that the the key
Point here is that all these major
Publications in terms of American
newspapers in terms of broadcast media
are struggling to hold audience and so
what you're seeing overwhelmingly is
that these audiences are becoming more
fragmented and therefore if you're a
news executive you are more focused on
maintaining a niche inside um
of broadcasting or news publishing what
does this mean well it means that for
example you know just take a look any
evening on your cable spectrum and what
you'll see is MSNBC going far left
you'll see far Fox News going far right
CNN struggling for some identity and
losing numbers like bleeding uh C-SPAN
does pretty well but of course they're
not rated and they're just public
service but I'm talking about in the
commercial realm you think about what's
there in terms of American women I know
you know my wife my wife watches endless
hours of CSI Law and Order you know they
know exactly where you can you know find
a woman's eyeballs you know and then
there's for young males I guess there's
Spike and for kids you know um
Nickelodeon and the like Disney Channel
huge ratings for these things but again
breaking down the audience in a way that
prevents to my mind as a journalist the
comment telling the common sharing of an
American Experience of the telling of a
tale now I say that with full
realization that for most of American
life we have not had the common sharing
but the audience has been an elite in
other words these are stories about
powerful people that are being told to
powerful people people who have money
who have the ability to go out and buy
the products that are being advertised
uh in the course of these news
Productions what what happens then in
terms of minority news today is that
Minority news uh if you look at
Publications like ebony jet Essence and
like often times they become vanity
Publications it's not the case that they
are taking on difficult issues about uh
social crisis or speaking to uh you know
the most
compelling uh but sometimes TDY story of
life in minority America and especially
among the poor to the contrary they are
exercises in saying look you know here
is so and so who's just been promoted to
vice president of EX company and is an
Exemplar or here is a fabulously Rich
music star or singer and their lavish
new house and the way that they're live
and large that is in their publication
that's what they're featuring and uh if
you're even talking about sort of
national politics something like uh
ebony didn't cover it for most of its
life Jet Magazine had uh Simeon Booker
and I think it's called Washington wire
or ticker or something like that and it
have just little bulletins about the
activities and often times the social
activities of prominent black
politicians uh in Washington on the
national level so when you're talking
about well do we get sufficient coverage
of critical issues uh in white
newspapers I would say we don't get
critical important coverage of these
issues in any Publications for the most
part uh and even today in what remains
of the black press um they don't cover
some of these crises with any sense of
urgency and what you get and we've
talked about the radio often times being
sort of a daily drum in the black
community the morning especially the the
morning radio shows um you get sort of a
a collection of people saying yeah well
this is kind of the established popular
opinion this is the way we think this is
going but there is no commitment to
putting feet on the ground in terms of
in investing money and create and and uh
placing journalists in position to tell
you critical stories time and again with
any sense of uh
dispatch with any sense of trying to dig
deep into a story and find systemic and
uh identity of political power players
who have their finger on levers that are
causing distress in these lower income
communities it just doesn't exist
another point to be made here is as we
were talking about the internet is that
you will see now obviously you have
tremendous disparities in terms of
internet access especially in minority
and poor
communities um but what you're seeing is
the black middle class and especially
black intellectuals they are creating
space on the internet and so a
publication like the Washington Post now
has the root uh and there other similar
Publications I think AOL had I forget
the name of these uh sites but but
places where what you're seeing is
educated uh pretty much younger black
people Gathering to have the kind of
conversations that you spoke about
coming out of the black scholar of the
black scholar at a time so that's
occurring but if you're talking to me
about uh lower income people of any
color using the internet as a place
where they could organize where they
could mobilize where they could um
create common identity and common
purpose I don't see it I could be out of
the loop but I tend to be aware if not
involved and I just don't see it at this
point I I would uh mention that uh a
young friend of mine his name is James
Bernard some years ago he founded a
magazine called the
source and James um went to Brown went
to Harvard Law School he's
African-American from Nashville um but
the source if I don't know if any of you
have ever heard of that magazine in the
audience it was really directed at and I
get this all mixed up the hip-hop
generation or you know x x I forget YX I
don't know which one um but uh
he uh since he had legal training he
actually scrutinized the contracts of a
lot of these rappers he uh wrote in the
magazine how they didn't own the cars
that they drive around in they didn't
own the houses that you know they were
this this company was paying for this
and that company for that then he
critiqued their lyrics you know and said
well what does it mean if you're saying
this is a and black women are
then what does that say about
you what does that say about your
children what does that you know he
would say things like like that in in
the magazine and he had a real following
he got death threats he had to go
underground he had to back away from the
magazine um very you know and he's not
publishing it right now
um that is I think a one sign um that
there's a real problem I mean that the
community itself doesn't want to hear
bad news no some in the community do but
there's an element in the community that
is intolerant right of discourse and
that's a real problem and there's not a
lot of conversation about that there's
no coverage of that well I mean let me
just pick up on this I don't just
to in my life as a journalist
obviously when I identify what I think
of as points of crisis in the minority
community and write about it it creates
tremendous discomfort in the minority
Community you would think that from my
perspective as the journalist there
would be an appreciation the idea well
wait a second someone
with someone who commands an audience
who has a pen who has a voice is paying
attention but to the contrary the
response is often times why are you
holding us up to scrutiny and to
criticism um in the white world and why
are you earing Dirty Laundry might be
the shorthand uh for saying this the
most recent book that I wrote picked up
on Bill
themes mhm uh and the book's title tells
you a lot book was called enough phony
leaders deadend movements culture of
failure in Black America and what we can
do about it now when you write a book
that talks about some of the points that
you were touching on half of our
children not graduating from high school
60% of the people in jail being people
of color when you start writing about uh
50% of the Hispanic population being
being born to single mothers 70% in the
black community breakdown of the black
family there are people who say you know
I don't want to hear about this this is
not what I and and these are the same
people who will say you know I want to
read another uh story about Michelle
Obama's Fashions but they don't want to
hear about reality when it comes to the
struggles that are occurring in the
black community and the exception would
be say well if there is an example where
there's a white policeman
involved then I'll hear about that story
but if it's the story about the problems
that
are bedeviling and I think crippling so
much of the black community let's say
failure to appreciate value of
Education you people there is not much
of a market for this story in fact you
will be hounded as you as you describe
your friend and you will be in my case
you know it's easy to pick on me you can
say well gee you you know you work for
fox you work for NPR you work for the
Washington Post you know um people will
raise all kinds of things even if you
were running the source I think it's
only Fox that people would ask you even
if you were running the source which is
intended to serve that generation people
would say well that's contrary to what
we were picking up the source for you
are putting us down and I you know this
this is not about the white newspaper
per se this is about uh the
sensibilities in the black community and
in that middle class black community
remember that again these Publications
these broadcast outlets in terms of
serving that middle class black
community um is trying to give ear or
voice to issues that often times uh not
just Escape that middle class Community
but are of pro are problematic for uh
the poor and the poor AR are not the
ones reading those papers or watching
those broadcasts can I add one thing I
think there's a strata in the black
community ironically many of them
benefited from civil rights legislation
such as black elected officials who
represent majority black districts and
they want turnout to be as low as
possible they want the PE the only
people they want voting on the three
people that voted for them last time and
they don't want issues they don't want
people excited um and then you have some
others who um make a living I I brought
in the NAACP legal defense fund when I
worked at public housing to talk about
to address public housing residents and
they decided to talk about reducing
sentences for black uh crack dealers
because they were getting longer s
sentences than white powder dealers and
this is what they chose to talk about
the to the public housing audience and
the public housing audience almost
grabbed them physically because they
wanted if you had given them ropes
they'd have strung up the crack dealers
like from trees that is not what they
wanted to hear from you know the legal
defense fund that was supposed to be
quote unquote representing them this is
such an important point and as a
journalist I find if you're dealing with
the leadership the leadership will say
you know it's about crack cocaine versus
powdered cocaine and sentencing and you
say well wait a second have you talked
to people who say they don't want any
kind of cocaine that if you put crack
cocaine houses in a community it not
only drives down residential uh housing
values it just creates Street crime it
leads to all sorts of dereliction people
don't want it they that's the the issue
about who the whether this drug deal or
that drug deal is getting a heavier
sentence is not the issue for the people
in the Comm but you know you it's hard
to sell I what I uh I I agree and I uh
think that one of the um shortcomings of
the Civil Rights Movement was really
dealing with the
economy um and underlying a lot of um of
tension right now um is
um uh a real absence um of focus on
elected leadership of elected leadership
black leadership and others to address
fundamental problems like jobs
fundamental you know the um people can't
pay their mortgages and raise their
families you know those kinds of things
and instead of dealing with that a lot
of officials move on to other issues
like skip Gates being chased off
arrested off of his porch you know I
know that's unfortunate but you know
what
um that is not a vital issue um in Black
Amica it is just not a vital issue um
what is really concerning to me is there
was an election um this week in New York
and in several um sections of the city
turnout was actually zero this was a
runoff and in some of the poorest
sections of of the city turnout actually
was zero and John Lou was running for
city com controller the city com
controller of New York
controls about $60
billion and he is the sole decision
maker on where that money is invested 60
billion dollar this should be a m New
York un black unemployment in New York
is almost 20%
officially this should have been a major
issue a major issue and it is um there's
been so little discourse so little
conversation so little education about
this issue turnout actually hit zero to
me that is like the the underlying kind
of dynamic one could also say I think
that it that it's marks a failure of
Journalism broadly that that uh this
kind of question is these kinds of
questions were not systematically
publicized to to to make the make this
make the new make New York citizens more
aware of what was going on in in in in
the election I think there was a piece
in the times today about it or maybe it
was yesterday but something like 2% of
the population voted in that election
correct a shocking thing we we we're
going to make our transition now to the
to the uh Open Mic section where you
folks uh ask questions and make quick
comments so get your questions ready I
thought that uh while you're getting
ready for that it's of often the case if
I just say we're opening it to questions
there's five minutes of dead silent so
imagine this is the dead silent moment
and I'll I'll ask a transition question
not usually when I'm around people kind
of jump at me but uh I I so one uh uh
issue that's come up a little bit in in
in in the conversation here I wanted to
uh um ask Juan about uh many people have
made comments to me about this when uh
over the last few weeks because they
knew you were coming and I'm sure you've
faced this question before but let me
put this in the in this in the uh in the
least controversial way I can do you
find or have you experienced any tension
in your roles as an NPR commentator and
as a fox commentator do you sense that
the cultures of those two news
environments make different
demands sure they're huge hug hugely
different obviously one is a visual
medium one is an oral medium so radio
versus TV have tremendously different
demands to make on me as a journalist uh
and then the fact is that fox is a cable
outfit and that it competes in this very
aggressive commercial Arena and has
identified itself as a conservative
Outlet these are this is very different
than the kind of sensibilities that
operate at at NPR NPR's problems are
that people would identify it as a
liberal outfit um and that it struggles
against that identification makes every
effort possible not to fall into that
Niche it obviously it fails sometimes
but there's a real effort to try to be
uh a neutral source of news um and fox
has no such
aspiration um what you get in terms of
the the dynamic of the
presentation is again on cable news the
idea is to be as provocative
argumentative as possible um you want
the visual to be as appealing sexy
outrageous violent as possible that's a
different Universe than NPR where you
know my kids say Dad can you change the
channel this is boring this is what you
know it sounds like they're droning on
and on here that's a different universe
and a different sense of how what you're
trying to uh achieve in reaching the
audience and the whole business about
storytelling a different sense of time
how much time is available for any
segment on TV versus how much time is
available for any segment uh especially
on our longer news magazine shows on NPR
less so there there is a real battle
over time when you come to things like
Morning Edition and all things
considered but you know we can have
extended interview if you're tuning into
NPR and you hear Terry gr on fresh air
that that kind of length for an
interview just doesn't exist anywhere on
TV much less the cable dial so there's
huge differences um the you know I would
point to things like um people don't
even know who the host are on NPR you
definitely know in terms of prime time
real estate you know who Bill O'Reilly
is you know who Shan Hannity is you know
those Prime Time Players that's a again
a huge difference in terms of
personalities driving the news and
driving the presentation and the spin of
the news versus what's going on on uh
national public radio so huge
differences uh that I think are pretty
obvious to anybody who comes in contact
with them and for me what it means often
times as a voice in these arenas for
example if I'm on NPR I might be you
know like tomorrow morning I'll be
talking with Steve inep and we're going
to be talking about sort of the liberal
politics and its response to Obama over
the last few weeks uh you know and it'll
be a one-on-one conversation with
someone that you know is trying to pull
out of me as because of because I have
great sources and I'm in contact with
all these players pull out of me an
understanding of how the White House is
reacting and how the political players
on the left are reacting if I was doing
that on Fox I would be likely in
conversation not only with the anchor
but maybe another person and the anchor
of course would be more likely to be
someone who leaned to the right and they
might have someone who was a right-wing
ideologue on and they might go first and
then they come to me and then I'm trying
to like deconstruct what I think is the
spin and Distortion that the other
person has put forward before I even get
to trying to make my point and we're
involved in a fight in which they're
trying to picture the left in sort of
you know demonic uh terms and I'm saying
wait a second I don't think that that's
the whole story here I think there's
some real issues beneath it so again the
role I play there is much more of the
foil and the the other the voice that
comes in and says wait a second here's
my vision of it which differs from yours
versus the role I'm playing on NPR which
is uh someone who has depth of
understanding uh
sources uh level of experience that
would help the audience to have
perspective and context for the flow of
news that they are
consuming we're ready for for questions
people there are microphones here it
would be helpful if you gave your name
because this is being recorded and uh
you'll be uh known for all of eternity
on our on our
archives um I'm just gonna jump in here
because it's it's kind of a followup oh
sorry I'm mateline I'm a graduate
student in the comparative media studies
Department here um a follow up about
your experiences working at MPR um this
isn't quite the theme but I'm very
interested in in your opinion
in these forums we often talk about the
sort of decline of newspapers and the
decline of media and midly I live in a
bubble I listen to NPR all the time um
but it seems like NPR is doing a good
job of weathering the storm from at
least the outside it seems like um
things are going okay for for radio
shows and I was wondering if that was
just my opinion as an outsider who
doesn't know anything or if you have any
view about the survival of radio
journalism well uh first thank you so
much for listening to
NPR um you know we love our audience I'm
sorry terrific uh we have a very loyal
audience and it's been a growing
audience after 911 NPR saw a spike in
listeners and we have been able to
maintain hold on to those listeners for
the most part there's been a slight
decline over the last two qu ERS I
believe but uh it's been slight so what
you see is this there's a tremendous
rush to the kind of Journalism on radio
that's provided by NPR now I will say
that I think that this is an oasis in
terms of radio land I think what you're
what I think in your question it sounded
as if you had NPR as synonymous with all
radio journalism and I don't think that
I don't think you're going to find much
like NPR anywhere else on the radio dial
um that what you get are these uh talk
shows where I think people are seeking
to be
outrageous provocators mostly from the
right um and in terms of news content uh
maybe the top of the hour news from CBS
or Bloomberg or fox or somebody but it's
just but it's it's it's basically
reading the headlines and it doesn't
have the kind of depth and it certainly
doesn't have the investment in putting
corresponden around the country or
overseas that you will see uh with
national public radio now you spoke
about the economic crisis that's
afflicting all of American journalism um
and suggested well you guys seem to be
thriving well you know from the inside
perspective we have just laid off about
8% of our staff at National Public Radio
and
um the ability to move around to pay for
things again has been limited by the
impact of the recession you know major
gifts Investments and the kind of uh
dividends that would come off of the of
that money it's not there in some cases
that money has declined in absolute
value uh given what's happened on Wall
Street and that impacts our ability to
function so you know that is impacting
the journalism from my perspective as a
journalist I notice it I feel it I'm
just thrilled that you don't feel it
that you still feel that the product is
something that uh can give you driveway
moments where you want to stay in the
car and listen to NPR that's that's our
goal and we hope that you're getting
more of
it well I just want to say that I I
think that um some of the in a lot of
ways uh radio uh particularly right-wing
radio has um become the real political
party sort of um networks in in society
in that you know political parties don't
really exist as real organizations
anymore they're they're more campaigns
and then money is raised for a campaign
around a particular candidate but as
organizations that sort of organize
dialogue about politics on an ongoing
pis basis they don't really do that and
on the right you have radio ideologues
that actually do mobilize people um and
a lot of people sort of identify with
some of these right-wing um radio hosts
and then on the left I don't think you
have a similar sort of thing as as Juan
was saying earlier I don't I'm not
saying there should be like a left-wing
ideological kind of you know equivalent
to right-wing ideologue so because I
think the whole thing is a little bit
dangerous um actually and one of the um
things I really hoped for or hoped would
happen out of Obama's campaign was that
all of these volunteer groups and all of
these participatory groups that were
coming together across the country and
there were thousands of them would
somehow continue and that they would
organize dialogues in communities um
independent of not just like take orders
from you know um Rah Emanuel or
something but they would actually
organize dialogues and around important
issues and function as a real party M
and the Obama folks have dropped it I
mean they send emails out and things
like that but no one has really picked
up on that momentum the excitement and
enthusiasm that I saw uh from people who
participated in that lots of young
people it's been dropped and I think
that's a a dangerous thing in an
economic crisis with two Wars a lot of
contentious issues um being uh debated
and important issues being debated and
we really don't have good forums I don't
think um for people to come together and
really work these issues through through
and it's different sitting in a chair
listening to someone talk to you as
opposed to really being in in a form
where you can have depth and complexity
and nuance and so forth and I think all
of those things are critical for a
democracy
um uh thank you for your comments really
fascinating uh I'm Ian condry I teach in
uh comparative media studies here at MIT
um and my question is about uh
journalism in terms of editors
especially and sort of the discourses of
what counts as news um I spent a few
years working for a Japanese newspaper
and I I work on Japanese media um and
one of the things that struck me is that
being outside of the media it's very
easy for us to criticize the media but
once you're inside it it's a really much
more complex uh system where it's hard
to know where exactly the pressure
points ought to be to change things um
and one of the things I've noticed sort
especially watching coverage of Japan
over the years is how the stories of
Japan that seem to actually get
published and this one of the things I
experienced working for the newspapers
that a lot more stories are written that
are actually published and so sort of
getting through the editors and up the
chain to actually getting in the paper
was quite a trick and that it seems that
a lot of the stories that are published
fit into already uh accepted discourses
of what the news is and how we should
spin things and I don't know if that's
your experience but uh if so I I'm
wondering about the ways that uh those
might change I mean in Japan case it's
you know anything about those wacky
Japanese uh seems to be the one that
gets through the most easy you know
they're they got all these crows in
Tokyo and they're terrified of crows or
you've got a woman who makes a a a
costume that turns into a vending
machine so she can run away from robbers
you know there's a kind of way of
thinking about Japan uh as being this
other thing and those stories get
through and a lot of other things seem
to be get missed and so this question of
sort of the important stories not
getting through and where as gates gates
and the celebrity Factor plays a big
role it seems to me in the stories that
do get through uh so I guess I'm I'm
curious if there are ways in which uh
what's decided is news and is not news
is changing and if so sort of how uh
that process could be improved to deal
more directly uh with the important
issues uh that are facing especially uh
the black community in America thank you
well it's uh Professor conri it's sort
of
across lines here
that this that I hear this complaint for
example you hear complaints about uh as
we think think about Africa for example
news from Africa that It just fits into
stereotypes of Africa it doesn't really
bring you a sense of the dynamic of life
in Africa it doesn't even bring you
stories about
darur uh in a measure that would be
commensurate with the tragedy that's
taking place there and so you know why
don't we pay more attention or in the
examples that you offered about Japan
why is it that we seem to go for what
seems comical versus again quality of
life in what is a major Power Industrial
and economic power in the world but the
fact is that what you're doing if you're
the editor of one of these Publications
and I'm talking about New York Times as
well as a smaller paper in the midwest
is you are creating a publication for
your readers and what they're interested
in is news that directly affects them uh
as much as possible so if you are
writing about Japan if they see that
it's something that's kind of quirky and
humorous okay but how many readers are
truly sufficiently interested in
Japanese politics to be curious about
the inside baseball of the arguments
that have taken place that led to a
transition recently in political power
that was a generational shift for Japan
maybe one story when the election is
done at most but in terms of the regular
coverage and a proper appreciation of
the importance of this story you're
never going to get it in an American
Paper uh this leads me to a larger point
about being inside American papers at
this moment when there's so much
economic pressure that if you do focus
group with American
readers what you see is that they are
interested basically in local news
that's they want the sports page the
guys will get the sports page we cannot
get young women to read the newspaper
and I don't care what newspaper it is
young women will say you know they're
busy with relationships they're busy
with school um they'll say the newspaper
seems to repeat itself a lot that it's
cyclical it was the they were writing
about
Obama and Healthcare yesterday and I see
it's the same damn thing today and I'll
wait you know the biggest newspaper for
them might be the Thursday or Sunday
paper with the coupons but in terms of
the news content not that's not what's
driving them so we have a hard time
getting young women to read the paper at
all young men will be drawn in by the
sports page and the question is whether
or not they ever make the transition to
the
front um and the struggle the overall
struggle is again to to meet the desire
to read about themselves in the paper
they want local news they want local
sports they want more of that they do
not want uh more in-depth coverage of
international news sad to say and they
don't particularly have an appetite even
for national news coverage it's local
news maybe state news but that's what is
going to uh result in the sale of more
newspapers and one last point on this
when I ask young people where do you get
your news from they say things like John
Stewart Stephen coob right Oprah Leno
Letterman uh Howard
Stern um you know some of the comic
people who are the dis jockeys in the
morning the shock jocks in the morning
and all that um and they you know even
if they say oh yeah but I watch cable
they'll start talking about Rachel
mattow or
uh Bill
O'Reilly um Lou dos and I think to
myself oh my gosh you know they haven't
talked about one reporter yet somebody
who actually goes out talks to people
gets news collects news and tries to
present it in a way that I think is
impartial they haven't talked about one
such person yet so that's the
audience now if you're the editor and
you know that's the
audience you want to serve serve that
audience you don't have to be a bad
person or Craven to say I'm simply
trying to hold this audience how do I
hold this audience well it's not by
giving them more about the intricacies
of Japanese
politics that's not going to hold their
eyeballs or hold their attention so the
implication of this one is that the
for-profit model is no good that's true
but it's also I thought that you were
going to say the implication this is
that the audience no what the audience
wants to me is is very curious the
audience will sit in front of me in a
setting like this and say you know why
is the news media failing us why isn't
the news media doing a better job and
then I think to myself you know what
what do you
watch what do you read or what do you
fail to
read over on this
side hello my name is Joanna I'm a
reporter um and I'm interested in in
knowing um your opinion about the ways
in which the media reflect intellectual
uh black
community um and uh how how the
intellectual black people uh appear in
the media what is the the image and uh I
would also like to know your opinion
about um the ways in which we can better
reflect our multi-racial
societies black inter uals in the media
media and multiracial
societet well we were just having a
conversation Professor Thompson
about
uh areas especially on the internet
where I think there is uh more
communities of black intellectuals
reacting following the news having
conversations with each other um so that
occurs I think on the internet to some
extent not to any large extent but it's
is there I think it's present if you
were seeking it you could find it if
you're talking about in the course of uh
mainstream
or mostly uh news organizations or news
products that are oriented for a
mainstream mostly white audience then I
think the whole question
of intellectual thought is really in
short supply I don't care what color it
is
uh if you think I often think of you
know news as related to ideas news as
related to events and I think at the
bottom of this I would put news as
related to personalities we have lots of
newses related to personalities people
relate to other people they're curious
Etc um in terms of events if you look at
the way that news is presented it's
often times in terms of a key meeting a
key uh Rally or March um
a key decision has been made a key paper
has been issued uh you know in
Washington or something like that key
report those are events but in terms of
ideas of terms of coverage of ideas it
is scant uh because again you're talking
about what is going on in larger streams
and it may be um difficult to personify
to put it in terms of a human being um
which is the way that most people
apprehend the news coming out of
mainstream media in the country so if
you're then breaking it down and saying
well what's going on in terms of black
intellectuals in the country then you'd
go back to personalities for example one
of the powers of Professor gates at
Harvard is that he is a celebrity
personality so that when he engages in
his work as a professor he has a greater
chance to get into that mainstream media
an idea um but they would largely couch
it in terms of some work or effort
that's being done by a celebrity black
professor at Harvard
University um you know similarly um
Cornell West shifting from Harvard to
Princeton or saying get gets more
attention than any work that Professor
Gates on Professor West may have engaged
in he hasn't done any lately well I
didn't want to get into now you're no I
mean he hasn't written any that's why he
shifted uh and and uh and you know you
think about
again
in areas of let's say critical critical
theories of race relations in the
country it would have to reach the point
where it was a matter of
policy uh argument that was going to be
implemented before I think it would get
become evident in the kind of uh
coverage that you would see in a
mainstream newspaper or here in radio or
television it be it's pretty rare I I
have no noticed uh some interest on some
of my like black colleagues in doing
more um public media uh so her um
Melissa Harris lacewell at Princeton was
on CNN a lot recently drinking water um
Carol Swain who's a friend of a
professor over there uh has been on um
uh on CNN you know and other networks
recently um Larry Bobo at Harvard has
been writing for the roote and you know
I I encourage that Trend um because I
think a lot of professors by the time
they get tenure well when they're trying
to get tenure they're writing for
journals that 12 of their colleagues
read and you know write letters on their
tenure cases and they're sort of
conditioned not not to write in ways
that you know a popular audience could
actually interpret what they're saying
um and then by the time they get tenure
they sort of of think that's how you do
things and I encourage this trend of you
know um black professors and students
even getting really engaged uh with
issues that are being talked about and
debated in Washington or in their state
houses or whatever I personally have
found that newspapers are interested um
in carrying you know having you write
something like that um I wrote something
for the Boston Globe recently that the
mayor's office asked me to write because
they they said somebody has to like it
was around green jobs and the Building
Trades actually went to the globe and
got the globe not to do the article um
but I thought that was fun um be because
sounds like a news story itself well you
know I I this is Boston um and there
have been historic issues between the
Building Trades and minority communities
over jobs and who gets publicly funded
construction jobs and they just didn't
want this sort of you know this kind of
out there for the public but we have a
lot of people at this campus and on
other campuses who are working on these
issues and the city should know what the
data is and they should know the history
and I think those of us in universities
ought have an obligation actually we're
subsidized by the way um sitting here
even though we're a private university
we don't pay taxes I think we have an
obligation um to use some of our
skills that we've gained for public for
the public so I I want to encourage that
and I think I think it could
be uh I don't want to say transformative
but I I think it could actually help a
lot in addressing economic issues or
other things that I mentioned were
problems that elected officials aren't
talking enough about I think it could
help on accountability issues you know
because sometimes we can say things
we're not going to get fired by getting
in the face of an elected official or
something like that so I think it's
important uh we're we have about a
little less than 20 minutes left let me
encourage especially we on the panel but
also you who ask questions to be
concise um good evening my name is
zindel Brooks and I'm actually a student
in civil engineering here at MIT and I
have a question on this lack of a
compelling black news media Forum what
role has Oprah played in all of this has
she improved the situation at all or has
she brought us to the edge of an
abyss well I guess you you assume that
Oprah is a
newscaster of course she's she's such a
powerful voice and she seems to have
open the way for this type of for um has
she chosen not to go down that path
she's opened the P for what for him let
since what she said wasn't on the mic
she said what what what the questioner
said was that Oprah has such a powerful
voice and created a kind of forum that
might have gone in a in an information
or a news Direction but hasn't is that
right right well I don't I don't think
that she open that path I think that
what she does is a show again if you
think about what she's trying to do
she's trying to reach women
middle-aged whelmingly white women um
with a program that can compete with the
other talk shows of the day and she has
had ex extraordinary astounding success
and she's tremendously effective and her
new magazine Oprah the O the magazine
just tremendous and her book clubs but
it is for that American middle-aged
white Suburban woman audience at heart
that's what she does I don't think of it
as a news program now it can be a highly
informative program it can be a
sensitive II program it can be one that
prompts you to cry or to laugh that's
the best of Oprah um and occasionally
she might turn attention to something
that she views as an important news
story and try to help you to appreciate
especially by again featuring
personalities that then come on the show
and make the issue real for that
audience um but again you know from my
perspective and I hope I'm not
coming across as some old contener as
coot but I don't think she's a news
person I don't think that's what she's
trying to do I think she's trying to um
cater to I think she does the best of
those talk shows aimed at American women
and so and she does an astounding job of
that uh but that to me is different than
saying that that I would hold her to
account for not doing more news or not
doing more serious discussions uh
opening that form I think is what you
meant when you said open that form
that's not her goal and that's not what
she's competing uh to offer to
advertisers who pay her highly for
holding that
audience over
here hello I'm Victoria I'm a freshman
here and I heard you talk about how like
you have these roles and in your Fox
News and other places and how like they
sort of lead to a packaged sort of media
style especially with the competition
between the three networks I was
wondering how like the spin of the news
and the drive to like characterize it or
like no character character yeah that's
what I'm trying to say and use like
buzzword all the times limits or affects
um the depth of discussion of minority
topics especially with the rise of like
a lot of minority
commentators well it's that's
interesting what I'm saying is that you
do have if for example if you're on
cable television news and again the time
is going to be tight and you're going to
have people using sound bites and
visuals to Advantage in the course of a
debate you have got if you can
speak in visual terms in other words
create pictures with your words
especially play to pictures that might
be being shown as you are speaking you
are in an advantage right that's that's
to your advantage uh if you you said
Buzz words I think in terms of sound
bites are things that are going to
really stick in the person who's
listening who's having visual input as
well as uh you know intellectual input
your voice your words uh that you have
to be aware of it if you're in that
environment similarly or dissimilarly if
you are on the radio and again you're
trying to create those word pictures too
but you have a different kind of
environment and you're not in course of
debate where you are being contradicted
or someone else is firing off at you or
interrupting you it's it's a different
reality and it's a different experience
for the consumer of news in that
environment so you're saying well how
does that
impact
uh depth of discussion about minority
news in the
country he did like of parody how on
some topic he like just did a bunch of
Clips F of talking about um an event
that occurred and they all said the same
thing over and over and over this is an
again she's not on the mic so I'm going
to partly repeat you the example she
chose was from the John Stewart show and
uh why you you can respond now that's
enough to no but you know for me again
sitting here you know with this MIT
audience you know I hear about Oprah I
hear about John Stewart you know but
what they're doing in his case is he is
making fun of the politicians and he's
showing how in
fact I'm news anchors news Med but but I
think he's making fun of a political
class and what you're seeing there is
he's saying you know look these people
repeat the same kind of message they all
get locked into the same language time
and again isn't that funny but is it
revealing is it truly going to the
essence of the discussion debate I think
even by his own standards he says you
know what I do is phony news I'm not
doing the news how can you think this is
news well let me tell you he's fooling a
lot of people a lot of people buy into
that but I thought that you were saying
also how does this impact coverage of
news as it relates to the minority
Community I think that's a very
important subject because again given
the high percentage of stereotypes that
exist about people of color immigrants
women in American society a lot of these
the the kind of sound bites a lot of the
kind of py language that gets used in
that environment I think does not allow
us to really come to grips with issues
so that people sort of automatically
take sides I think people are uh very
sensitive about well if I say this it
may come across to somebody as racist or
somebody May shout back that's a racist
or that's a racial statement um and
there is as a result a lack of that kind
of important discourse you just heard
you know Professor Thompson talking
about some really critical issues but
you would never hear that kind of thing
uh
you know because either they would be
talking about the celebrity or what the
celebrity said or is it outrageous or is
it offensive as opposed to the actual
content and how it is impacting or the
consequence it's having on the lives of
people in our
community um which side are we on
this longer I stand here the longer my
question gets in my head but U my name
is Sandra Larson I'm a freelance writer
so um you've talked about some
interesting things about the about a
debate among blacks and how how that
might be you how that might have
declined some but from a perspective of
um mainstream
media I want to know what you what
coverage you think is actually most
lacking um and maybe the better question
is which would be more important say in
terms of the African-American Community
um to cover more issues that are
uniquely African-American
or to just more routinely include
africanamerican examples and opinions
and characters in stories that are more
General and maybe I was wondering if you
had a couple of examples if you about a
national issue anything from um how
people are paying for college education
to the Foreclosure crisis to um global
warming issues that are dis reported
generally how what would it be more
important to focus in on a specific
aspect of it that means something to a
minority Community or just to always
include people of all types when
reporting a story well a lot of this is
generational for example there was a
time when people of color were not
included in sort of mainstream coverage
of politics or the
economy uh you know child care or
whatever just you you know because again
most of the audience for New York Times
or CBS News or NPR is white people and
so they're trying they're relating to
that audience and then there came a day
when you would see black faces pop up
left and right or faces of color of any
kind or you would see women pop up and
you say oh look now there is a greater
awareness of the diversity of the
audience and of people and of the
society and of course that's shifting as
we see now I think it's a third of the
American population made up of people of
color uh that shifting as you see women
come into more positions of prominence
in American Life life whether it's Sonia
soay on the Supreme Court where you just
had a you know the president basically
considered only women for that position
I mean that you know so the idea of you
know look at the highest most qualified
legal Minds in the country and look at
this group of women that's different um
but that's separate from the kind of
intentional use of saying we want to
make a presentation here that would
suggest that we are aware of racial
difference and we want to highlight
people of color or women in this
presentation that's kind that kind of
intentional coverage I think occurs
occasionally it often seems tendentious
or heavy-handed in some ways um and
again it's speaking to the sensibilities
of that overwhelmingly white audience
but when you get into these stories um
especially about poor people it's
handled in what I consider to be a very
intriguing way in that too
often poor is conflated with
minority and then all of a sudden you
think well gee everybody on welfare in
the country is black or you think
everybody who's involved with school
violence is black or something like then
you think wait a minute now you've gone
from one extreme to another and you are
in fact
distorting this story or you're not
covering the story fair you know like
the people will sometimes you'll see in
coverage of something like homelessness
they'll be showing you lots of white
people on the street you think wait a
second when I'm going down the street I
see a disproportionate share of people
of color among the homeless how come
when they but on TV they might be saying
you know we don't want to get any
complaints from anybody that says you
only
show people of color who are homeless
that's the kind of dilemma that the
editor or the the uh editorial director
can get caught
as they try to present that
story I I would just add that um I think
there are a couple of important issues
that um it would be helpful if they dug
more into black communities for example
and told the story a bit differently so
for example uh in Studies have shown in
Black communities it makes absolutely no
difference whatsoever whatsoever whether
a black person has health insurance or
doesn't have health Insurance in terms
of how often they see a doctor and
that's not true of the white community
and the black community makes no
difference whatsoever this is in studies
and the reason is because most black
communities have no Primary Health Care
System whatsoever and so they're no
doctors um except at the hospital so if
you get sick whether you have insurance
or whether you don't have insurance you
have to go to the hospital and wait in
the emergency room and it takes a long
long time a lot of people just get
frustrated with that they don't go
unless they're really really sick um so
the whole focus on public option no
public option um you know single pair no
single pair it's defined as like this is
The Cutting Edge thing that's like going
to make the difference for everybody and
whether or not they get to see doctors
that's not the full story and in
minority communities particularly black
communities that's not even the main
part of the story and so so I I that's
one example and another would be
mortgage foreclosure which uh
foreclosures are seven times higher uh
in Black communities and how did that
happen well that's kind of an important
story that you don't hear a lot about
how did it end up seven times higher in
Black communities um and it's an
interesting story you know about black
Brokers sell working for you know big
big mortgage brokerage companies selling
junk uh in Black communities and it
raises a real issue about if you're in
the black community where do you go for
Reliable information because I did focus
groups with a lot of these women who um
lost their homes and a lot of them
trusted these Brokers because they were
black um and because they felt they
wouldn't get screwed by these folks um
because you know historical ties
identity all this sort of thing and they
were getting screwed um so I think
that's an important story
personally right over here again we have
very we only have four minutes left
people so let's be very brief both
questions and answers okay so um first I
want or my name is AUD Bachi I a
freshman here and um I wanted to draw
attention to a reality first then ask my
question um you talked about um how it's
difficult for you being in the media to
get certain issues out into to the
public maybe not um in um a forum such
as NPR where you can kind of um talk
about your own in-depth in-depth
knowledge but um maybe in print media
newspaper where you have to go through
an editorial board or Fox News where um
the time segment is shortened um but in
saying that um it's difficult for you to
get your specific um issues out there
you also then went and criticized
another form of media
that um portrays issues in a way that
um that people who might not necessarily
listen to NPR or go and read the entire
newspaper would be um exposed to the
exposed to certain issues that they
might not have so you mean like non-news
sources like like the John Stewart show
or Oprah right yeah um so I kind of
wanted to ask you what you think the
responsibility of media is um seeing
that not all people are will to pay
attention to the issues that are you
know happening in Japan or are exposed
to the world so how do you think media
should appeal to all of these different
groups um the um the poor and the middle
class the upper class um exposing the
the truths that you seem to want to
discuss because in my opinion I think
Oprah does um bring the news to people
she does it in a different way than a
philosophical black scholar magazine
might but she brings the news to a group
of people that might not have seen it in
a way that they would be interested of
like in hearing so what's the
responsibility of media what would you
like it to
do what would I like it to do let me
just say that on Fox News I don't have
any trouble saying what I believe or
what I think is like kind of the heart
of the news I can say what I want to say
I'm saying it in a more combative
environment and and on NPR again time
constraints exist it's just again I
think it's a more deliberative and
direct form where I'm in conversation
with someone and I'm not having to be
argumentative I don't think that the
visuals are distracting you know I don't
think there's someone sitting there who
has collagen in her lips and shiny legs
you know I me I'm able to just you know
have this kind of more uh direct
conversation now with Oprah again what I
said to the previous questioner on this
topic was opra Will typically personify
an issue she'll say here's a person who
went through a personal struggle and an
issue and here's her story for the first
time speaking to you today and then of
course there may be celebrities involved
with it and celebrities who've made it
their cause and you can see pictures of
the celebrities traveling into this
ailing and distressed Community you know
that kind of thing and you're saying
well that makes it good for the audience
now we can appreciate and understand it
but from my perspective as a
professional journalist my perspective
is if I can get time and I can tell this
story in some such a way that really
speaks to why people let's say are
victimized by P predatory lending I'm
not trying to talk down to you I'm not
trying to say uh that I don't expect
that you are going to be able to
understand this unless I make the lead
about a specific mother although that
could be the way to do the story but
that's just one of the ways to do it and
I think that you have an obligation as a
highly educated American to be an
informed consumer of news if you're
waiting on Oprah to get to it there are
lots of stories she won't get to because
she's busy with Whitney Houston and I
love Oprah I just think Oprah is doing
great stuff and she does bring some
stories to attention that otherwise
would not have mass
exposure but God bless her she's not
responsible for you picking up a copy of
the New York Times once in a while and
seeing these stories uh as real
reporters are trying to tell them to you
uh in terms terms of the political
interplay that is causing these stories
to occur way before Oprah's producers
also pick up the New York Times then try
to figure out a way to package it that
would appeal to you as you are you know
watching TV and catching the Oprah show
in the afternoon so I I just I just want
all of you to have a sense of your
obligation to be informed consumers of
news and be able to distinguish between
what is personality driven presentations
even from someone with a very high and
positive level of Consciousness like
Miss Winfrey uh versus other
presentations that may not be so high-m
minded we're we're actually one minute
over we're going to we will stop at 7:05
there are three questioners I hope we
can get to all of you but you have to be
very brief and so do
you all right well hopefully we sto in
at 7:05 regardless it's isn't it 7:05
right now it's 7:01 okay um so the
official clock is in in the back if
you're interested I see um so I guess my
question is um I'd like to ask what is
the role of identity or image in media
consumption I think that's something you
guys both touched on uh so for example
of course someone like John Stewart who
is presenting himself as a somewhat
cynical and um sophisticated consumer of
news to people who perceive themselves
that way and or for example like the
black middle class um like you said
perhaps not so interested in the
New York com troller election because
perhaps they perceive themselves as
being unrelated to these issues
so how in media do you then engage
people who don't have them a self-image
of themselves in these sort of issues
you know poverty or these sort of things
and how do you engage them so that
they're actually interested in this news
because as you said otherwise they won't
listen to it you only have one sentence
to answer maybe we should take all three
questions well let me just try I just
try very quickly and say again what you
can try to do is bring a face a human
face to the story I think if you made it
plain upfront and the way the professor
Thompson did the connection between the
power of that office to control billions
of dollars that could lead to contracts
and where those contracts going are they
going into your community into your
pocket or they going into somebody
else's pocket then you could make it
real that that's the best that you can
do is to give it attention and again you
might see some Publications or broadcast
that would literally launch a Cru say
about it and say hey there's this office
people aren't paying attention but it
has tremendous power in your community
but that would be a rarity it's more
often the case that they would do it a
one-time hit and say hey look at the
connection between monies that are going
to be allocated and the power of this
person that will be elected um you know
that's the best you can do again I it's
interesting in these questions you guys
always put the onus on the media and I'm
thinking that's great we're trying but
strikingly it's the the audience uh that
prefers the cynical ironic attitude and
doesn't pay attention to the in-depth
kind of issues that I think are
available um but often times go
unattended and unappreciated by the
audience on the right so um given the
audience's uh rather shallow personally
personality based interest in the news
how do you see your societal impact in
terms of the information we put out
there for people my societal impact I
you know I hold myself to pretty high
standards in terms of trying to do
serious journalism and trying to help
people have an understanding of how
power Works uh you know I go back to
books like the power broker about Robert
Moses and you know you see the impact of
someone who in his case was unliked
official but decisions that he made so
my Fascination is with you know who gets
their garbage picked up who gets their
streets paved who gets to send their
kids to good schools um who feels safe
on the streets in their neighborhoods
gets good police protection gets good
fire protection what are the basics of
your life so if you're hearing me on Fox
if you're hearing me on NPR what I hope
I'm doing is giving you information that
makes you a more informed voter a more
informed activist in your community
someone that helps you to have a better
understanding of the forces at work that
are leading to decisions and policies
regulations that are impacting your life
and otherwise why would you listen you
know you have to trust me and expect
that I'm delivering something of value
that expands your base of knowledge
about a political Dynamic and if I do
that then I'm doing my job Final
question well pH go ahead I I just want
to say um MIT has some of the brightest
engineers and scientists in the world
and it is one of the most socially
ignorant places I've ever been in my
life um and so I I would say to all of
us and it's a little scary cuz people
are making devices here that have big
social impacts and there's very little
Consciousness about any of these things
we're talking about here tonight so I
think this isn't just a question for
journalists in terms of what are you
doing to have a societal impact I mean
what are each of you doing on this
campus to have an
impact Mr actually I don't have a
question I have comments okay uh I'm
Nolan buy I teach at uh Harvard's
Kennedy School of government I teach
courses uh concerning information
Communications I'm a former public
interest Communications lawyer uh I used
to run a law firm funded by the Ford
Foundation that allowed me to sue the
FCC and the government and media
companies and what have you but that was
way back then when there were
regulations uh what I'd like to do is uh
David uh concluded his initial remarks
in summary
and summing up U Phil and Juan's
comments by saying perhaps we've heard
uh examples of the failure of Journalism
um not only do I think that journalism
is failed but I think the uh the market
for uh good journalism in news has
failed but also I think that there's a
failure of government and of democracy
itself because in a democracy Citizens
need to be informed and one of the roles
of the media is to inform them and act
as a watchdog uh I'd like to uh suggest
uh some references for members of the
audience who would like a better
understanding of race politics and
American noan you have to do this in 30
seconds already two minutes over AB
mention that in
19668 for example or or 1976 no 1968
there was a number of uh blacks uh
African-Americans hired uh as reporters
in newsrooms it wasn't just in
Washington it was across the country and
and the reason was uh that was the year
that the so-called Kern Commission
report was published and that was a blue
ribbon committee headed by Oto Kerner um
appointed by uh Lyndon Johnson to study
the causes of civil civil disturbances
in American cities it was referred to as
the United States Riot commission report
uh and they concluded on that that white
racism was the primary cause and there
was a whole chapter on the role of the
media and it showed that the the media
either undercovered didn't cover or mis
covered uh the black communities and
immediately afterwards all of a sudden
black people all over the country were
qualified when the day before that was
published they were not the FCC even
changed its rules and began to require
employment uh accounts and Reporting uh
and it and and by 72 it said for the
first time that discrimination and
employment uh by broadcasters was not in
the public interest which implies that
before then maybe it was in any event i'
like to uh provide recommend three
resources that uh the uh those members
of the audience who would like to
further uh study this issue uh one being
the kernel commission report
itself uh it had no teeth but it had
great
recommendations uh the other two one was
one is the U Pew annual report stated
the news media 2009 which you can pull
off the internet and find out that it's
not just uh radio or television or
newspapers but also cable news and even
internet news which is losing audiences
perhaps people don't want to know
they're so distracted by other important
concerns and moreover perhaps the media
is not giving them what they need the
other one is one just published on
Friday and I'm holding a copy of it here
it's called the night Commission on the
information needs of communities in a
democracy I think it's something that
every everyone ought to read I don't
have time to go into details but that
should be a start thank you no we have
to stop I want to thank the audience and
thank our
speakers a pleasure to
you